c'est une première dans les yvelines les
patients atteints de la maladie
d'alzheimer de l' hôpital gérontologique
de chevreuse se sont vus offrir des
manchons ou plutôt des gants de
stimulation sensorielle une technique
importée de grande bretagne par une
écossaise kara garcia qui habite
aujourd'hui orgeval
j'aime bien tricoté et j'ai vu que ça se
faisait en grande bretagne ces manchons
et lors de vacances au mois de février
discutant avec ma mère qui fait aussi je
me suis dit tiens je vais voir en france
en rentrant si si ça se fait et sur
internet veut rien vu et puis j'ai
contacté le fournit de l'association
france alzheimer yvelines qui m'a dit
qu'effectivement il ne connaissait pas
mais qui serait très intéressé pour
développer l'idée les mouflons
distribuer ce vendredi 29 septembre ont
tous été confectionnés à la main
bénévolement par des couturières
amateurs tout a été pensé pour relaxer
les patients donc que nous avons des
textures de l'aisne qui sont
en sont différentes et des objets a
touché à manipuler un petit cordon et
puis à l'intérieur donc il ya aussi une
poche qui peut servir comme une petite
cachette en fait pour mettre une photo
vos choix et seydou et ben les mains
sont donc au chaud à l'intérieur et puis
on peut toucher l'extérieur après une
première prise en main verdict c'est
bonaventure pour l'hiver parce que c'est
pour l'hiver j'espère sa révolution
c'est bien ses plaies wissam en plein
sahel plaire à tout le monde
de nouvelles distributions gratuites
sont prévues dans les maisons de
retraite et les hôpitaux yvelinois dans
les prochains mois la maladie
d'alzheimer touche entre 15000 et dix
neuf mille personnes dans le département